معنا في الاستوديو الدكتور مهند مصطفى
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه على حماس ان
تستسلم هذا الامر غير ممكن واسرائيل تعلم
ذلك ونتنياهو يحاول ان يسوق هذا الخطاب
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي يطالب بتقديم
انجاز عسكري بعد اكثر من شهرين من بدء هذه
الحرب ونتنياهو حتى هذه اللحظه لم يقدم اي
انجاز عسكري يذكر حول الاهداف التي هو
وضعها وهي القضاء على حركه حماس ولذلك هو
يحاول وكانه ان يتحدث الى المجتمع
الاسرائيلي من خلال موقع النصر موقع الو
لكن هل هل هو هل هو مقتنع بما يقول يعني
هل هو مقتنع بان حماس يمكن ان تستسلم لا
طبعا هو غير مقتنع بذلك ولكن يحاول ان ان
يرفع معنويات المجتمع الاسرائيلي على ضوء
الخسائر الاخيره التي كانت وعلى دوء النشر
حول الاعداد الكبيره من الخسائر في في
الجيش الاسرائيلي من قتلى ومن من جرحه
ولكن ايضا هنالك في هدف اخر من هذا
الفيديو الهدف هو اعاده انتاج صوره جديده
للانتصار في الحرب هذه الصوره الجديده
تتمثل ليس في القضاء على حركه حماس وانما
في القضاء على يحيى السنوار ولذلك دائما
يتم ترديد هذا الاسم في داخل اسرائيل في
في وسائل الاعلام في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي خلق وكانه هنالك في حركه حماس
وفي يحيى السنوار القضاء على يحيى السنوار
سواء من خلال قط لاغتياله او اسره وكان
هذا هو الانتصار في الحرب نتنياهو يعلم ان
القضاء على حركه حماس هذا الامر غير ممكن
او على الاقل غير ممكن في في مده زمنيه
يعني ل لشهور او حتى لسنوات ولذلك يحاول
ان يعود ذلك من خلال الحديث عن استسلا عن
اغتيال قيادات في حماس كونك خبير في في
الشان الاسرائيلي وتتابعه بدقه هل الجمهور
الاسرائيلي
اي مقتنع الان ان اي الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحقق انجازات على الاقل لن نتحدث عن
الجمهور العام سكان مستوطنات غلاف غزه
وسكان مستوطنات ال الجبهه الشماليه هل هم
يعتقدون ان شيئا ما يتحقق على ارض الواقع
ابدا هم اكثر الشرائح السكانيه خيبه من
الجيش الاسرائيلي سواء سكان غلاف غزه
وايضا سكان شمال اسرائيل الذين لن يعودوا
الى بيوتهم وب داتهم في ظل الوضع الامني
الحالي الذي لا تستطيع اسرائيل حله ولذلك
هناك خيبه امل كبيره جدا في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لعده اسباب السبب الاول ان
الحرب طالت الحرب استمرت اكثر من 60 يوما
دون ان يقدم الجيش اي انجاز عسكري يذكر
يقدمه لى المجتمع الاسرائيلي المتعطش
للانتقام من من حركه حماس الامر الثاني ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يدعي كل الوقت حتى
قبل هدنه انه سيطر على شمال قطاع غزه
وفجاه تطلق حماس صواريخ على تل ابيب من
شمال قطاع غزه هذا يدل ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي متخبط ولا يقدم الصوره
الحقيقيه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي بدا
يسال اسئله كبيره جدا حول الحرب متى يمكن
او متى سوف تحقق اسرائيل اهدافها من هذه
الحرب بعد اكثر من شهرين على على عليها
ولذلك هنالك في خيبه امل من من من الجيش
الاسرائيلي من قدرته على تحقيق هذه
الاهداف واعتقادي انه اصلا في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لا لم يعد احد مقتنعا ان
اسرائيل تستطيع القضاء على حركه حماس هذا
الهدف لم يعد يتم الحديث عنه بشكل مكثف
كما كان في بدايه الحرب ولذلك هنالك في شك
في قدره اسرائيل على تحقيق هذا الهدف
وايضا هنالك في تغير في الخطاب الاسرائيلي
حتى الرسمي في الحديث بشكل مكثف ومثابر عن
هذا الهدف ويتم الحديث عن انجازات عسكريه
هنا وهناك من اجل ارضاء المجتمع
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو موجود في حاله ضغط
سياسي كبير جدا سوا
نقاله وسواء على المستوى الدولي بالنقد
الشديد على اسرائيل شكرا لك دكتور مهند
مصطفى الخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي